All right, thanks. Sounds good.
There are certain beliefs that we as human beings hold to deeply.
We believe in the value of truth.
We believe that beauty and morality are objective.
And we believe that we are agents that make genuine, free decisions that are up to
us. The problem is, is that some of us embrace certain worldviews that lead to a
denial of those common sense beliefs in practice.
But what happens is when we deny those common sense beliefs, they keep
popping up to the surface. So think of it like a beach ball.
If you take a beach ball and you try to push it under the water, what happens?
It keeps popping up to the surface.
You can't hold it down forever. Well, the same thing happens with people who embrace
world views that lead to the denial of common sense.
These beliefs are going to pop up.
Why can't naturalism account for agency?
Well, think about it. On naturalism there is no immaterial soul.
there's no self distinct from nature that can make meaningful genuinely
free choices although humans are more complex ultimately they are a
purely physical object like water when water is poured into a glass
what happens does it consider its options does it decide its shape or temperature
of course not because the laws of nature and the molecular structure of water it
will fit to the shape of the glass.
In naturalism, we human beings are like, well, this water.
Purely physical objects that all our behavior and our beliefs and actions simply
conform to the physical structure around us.
There is no agency. There are no genuine choices that we make as persons.
In fact, this is why many atheists will recognize and admit that if atheism is true,
agency is out the window. Sam Harris, one of the most well-known atheists today, in
his book titled Free Will says, quote, free will is an illusion.
I have to wonder why did Harris even bother to write the book?
After all, when you write a book, you think that you're writing down ideas that are
genuinely up to you and the goal is to persuade other people, other agents
to adopt your viewpoints. The very point of writing a book assumes that people can
be persuaded freely by your ideas.
And yet the premise of his entire book is that we don't have free will.
We're not genuinely free agents.
So again, his worldview says we are not agents.
But his actions portray and reveal his true beliefs.
At this stage, the problems with pantheism should be familiar.
since pantheism teaches that all is one there is no self distinct from
nature that can act purposefully so at its core pantheism
obliterates the idea of a free being that can make real choices
you know I would love the spaghetti with meatballs
comes with soup or salad? Salad, please. You can do house dressing, you can do
Caesar, you can do ranch. Let's go with house dressing on the side.
Thank you.
Let me ask you a question. Do you really believe that you are an agent who makes
genuinely free choices that are up to you?
Do you think you make choices whether they're big or they're small that really come
from your own agency? Of course you do.
In the big and in the small choices of life we all know that our decisions matter
and that many of those decisions in fact all of those decisions are up to us
imagine you're a high school senior rushing down the hall by the lockers trying to
get to class on time and seemingly out of nowhere a freshman bumps into you knocks
you over your books go all over the floor would it make a difference if he found out
that that freshman tripped as opposed to intentionally knocked you over
imagine after class your teacher takes you aside and very sincerely says, I
wanna compliment you on doing a great job in class today.
Your homework, the way you did on your test, your score, and even your discussion
was fantastic, good for you. It would make a difference if you found out that this
teacher was assigned by the state to give one compliment a day and your name
happened to come up alphabetically.
If someone you really liked asked you out to prom but you found out later that this
person was forced to ask you by his parents?
Would that make a difference? Look, the answer to all these questions is obviously
yes. We know that our ability to make choices and act as agents
matters. In fact, if we can't make choices that are up to us, virtues that we care
about so deeply like love and mercy and courage and sacrifice
lose their meaning. If we lose agency, everything of value
is gone. Of all the worldviews, monotheism best
accounts for agency. The world is, after all, the free creation of
a personal agent, God, and we have been made in his image and given the
responsibility and ability to make choices.
We are not simply part of nature.
We are agents who make meaningful choices within nature.
My favorite superhero by far is Spider-Man, aka Peter Parker.
His uncle Ben Parker once said to him, with great power comes great
responsibility. Well as human beings we have been given great power.
We have the ability to make meaningful choices that deeply affect the world
that we live in. and with that great power does come great responsibility.
We have responsibility to one another as human beings and if there is a divine
agent, God, we just might have responsibility to him too.